[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
ranking the 15
most evil dark witches and wizards in
the harry potter universe
things to bear in mind here are that i'm
not ranking them by
power but instead how sinister and evil
they are a lot of dark witches and
wizards didn't even make the list
so if you've got a list of your own i'd
love you to comment it
down below also be sure to let me know
what you think of
my list we've got a lot to get through
so let's get going
15. ethelred the ever ready
starting things off in a relatively
innocent fashion
at least as far as dark and evil wizards
go
we have ethel red the ever ready ethel
read the ever ready was a dark wizard
that existed in medieval times
known for getting offended for no reason
and taking out his anger by cursing
innocent bystanders
ethelred was a master of jinxes hexers
and curses
which he loved to use on innocence for
his actions he was eventually
imprisoned 14. mohan malicious
next up we have merwin the malicious an
evil
pureblood wizard that existed in the
medieval period
sometime between the 5th and 15th
centuries
during his lifetime merwin was a
dedicated practitioner of the dark aunts
and would conduct all sorts of twisted
magical experiments
using his uniquely hooked wand he had
dark grey
scabby looking skin which sort of
resembled lifeless human skin
and would often sport a long dark green
cloak
he was a scary looking guy and i have no
doubt that the experiments he would
conduct
had a lasting effect on his physical
appearance as we know her dark magic
can affect you in that way merwin was
single-handedly responsible for creating
a lot of the dark spells jinxes and
hexes
that sprang up out of the medieval era
and after his death
made it onto a chocolate frog card 13.
morgana leffe
mugana lafaye is actually a
pseudo-historical figure
and in many versions of folklore she is
the nemesis of the powerful wizard of
merlin
though not all of them morgana however
also exists in harry potter folklore
where she is portrayed as an extremely
evil witch and again the nemesis of
merlin
who went to hogwarts morgana is
considered by many to be the most
powerful witch of all time
and someone that truly hated every
aspect of goodness in the world
doing everything she could to fight
against it 12.
godlow godelo was one of the named and
known owners of the elder wand before it
came into the possession of the likes of
kirkorovich
grindelwald dumbledore etc if his name
sounds
doubly familiar to you it may be because
godallo wrote the famous dark magic
textbook
magique most evil a book containing
information on dark magic
including a passing reference to
horcruxes in its introduction
godelo used the elder wand to push the
boundaries of magic
and considered it to be his teacher
allowing the wand to help him write the
book
leveraging the powerful wand and using
it in accordance with his
dark mindset godallo ultimately created
a lot of dark spells
and curses godolo was eventually killed
by his own son
who locked him in the cellar in order to
gain ownership of the wand
11. grindelwald grindelwald was a dark
powerful and dangerous wizard born in
the year 1883
after a troubling childhood where he
showed an affinity for performing
dark magic he later became a huge threat
to the wizarding world
i bet a lot of you are wondering why
isn't he higher
on the list here's the thing about
grindelwald his ambitions of
establishing a
new world order were not primarily
driven by notions of evil or
darkness even if it looked that way at
times
grindelwald genuinely felt that what he
was doing was important for the world
and that is where his slogan was for the
greater good
he recognized that a lot of his actions
were wrong but ultimately believed that
his mission to establish the global
wizarding hierarchy
was important for wizard kind he felt
that he was just helping his people
even if it did oppress another people so
yes
grindelwald was dangerous powerful and
evil
but he certainly wasn't the most evil
10. bellatrix lestrange
bellatrix lestrange born bellatrix black
of the house of black
was an english pure blood witch who
would have attended hogwarts around
1962. she was one of if not voldemort's
most
loyal follower and her reputation for
administering hideous forms of magic
on unsuspecting wizards and witches in
the wizarding world
preceded her bellatrix was one of the
most twisted death eaters
and derived considerable pleasure from
torturing people
finding the suffering of others to be
amusing her favorite spell
was the cruciatus curse 9. barnabas
deveral
another previous owner of the elder wand
barnabas devil was a wizard from the
early 18th century
who earned quite the reputation as a
fearsome warlock
to put things plainly devil certainly
didn't use the wand for good
and for many years he leveraged the
powerful wand to tyrannize the wizarding
world
however eventually his reign of terror
ended when he was defeated
by a rival wizard 8. loxius
and here we have yet another previous
owner of the elder wand
loxius is the man who famously gave the
elder wand the name
the death stick and ruthlessly murdered
copious amounts of people
while using it loxius was a truly evil
dark wizard that many wanted dead
and according to dumbledore many claimed
to have been the one to finish him off
even his own mother this guy was almost
as evil as they come
7. emmerich the evil i mean this guy's
name says it all
his name has evil in it so i had to have
him reasonably high up on the list
the first official known historical
owner of the elder wand
is a wizard who went by the name
emmerich the evil though the wand may
have been in the hands of other wizards
before emmerich and
after antioch emmerich is the first
wizard on record to have possessed it
emmerich has been described as a
short-lived but exceptionally aggressive
wizard
that terrorized the south of england in
the early middle ages
6. gormlaith gaunt was an irish
pure-blood dark witch and the aunt of
his old sayer
who founded ilvermorny school of
witchcraft and wizardry
gormlaith who attended hogwarts herself
and was sorted into
you guessed it slytherin strongly
believed in pure blood supremacy
and had an intense hatred for anyone
that went against these extreme views
her hatred went so deep that she
murdered her own sister and
brother-in-law
she also shared something in common with
voldemort she had an inability to feel
love
if you're making a list of evil dark
witches you'd be wrong
not to include gormlaith 5. salazar
sutherin
salazar sutherin whose name you should
probably recognize
was a pureblood wizard that was born
sometime before 976
a.d famously or rather infamously
he founded southern house at hogwarts
slytherin is also infamous for his
disliking of muggleborn
students and was a strong proponent of
having only
pureblood students at hogwarts this
philosophy was ultimately passed on to
other slytherins his response to
muggleborn students attending the school
was to build the chamber of secrets
which concealed a basilisk that was
intended to purge the school
of these students as far as dark wizards
come
salazar slytherin is certainly up there
4.
hapo the fowl herpa the fowl was an
ancient dark wizard that hailed from
greece
it's entirely unknown when herpa walked
the earth but we do know that it was a
long
long time ago as he is commonly referred
to as one of the earliest known
dark wizards during his existence herpo
devoted his life
to producing and creating some of the
worst kinds of magic imaginable
producing the first ever basilisk some
speculate that herpo is the distant
ancestor of salazar sutherin
since he too could speak parcel tongue
herpo was eventually immortalized on a
chocolate frog
card 3. lord voldemort voldemort
i bet you didn't expect to see him here
but here's the reality
there were a lot of dog wizards before
him and many of them were horrific
born without the ability to feel love
and dropped off at an orphanage
voldemort certainly had a rough start
his perspective of the world was bleak
and he was essentially an emotionless
psychopath that sought power
and eternal life he wanted the pureblood
wizards to rise to the top of the food
chain
where they would enslave and kill
muggles and non-pure bloods
all under his regime he did a lot of
horrible things over the course of his
life
including murdering his own family
members and creating horcruxes
but he showed no mercy for any of these
things at any point in his life
voldemort is certainly evil 2.
rexidian rexidian was a dark wizard who
was said to have existed
during an unknown period in time it's
only referred to
as ancient he was a very talented dark
wizard
who was fully immersed in the dark arts
able to produce all sorts of evil
concoctions
and cast all sorts of sinister spells
but one thing that he always had trouble
with was what we now know to be
the patronus charm according to harry
potter law
rexydian it was massively magically
talented
was simply not able to produce the
patronus charm properly
because he was not pure of heart where a
normal witch or wizard
could expect to be introduced to their
spirit animal when casting the spell for
the first time
rexidian was met with maggots not only
that
but they were maggots that devoured him
engulfing his body
this is a testament to just how evil
rexidian was
he wasn't just not pure of heart
rexidian's heart was black
he was pure evil 1. acrysdis
a christus isn't particularly well known
but he marked his place in wizarding
history
as a practitioner of the worst kinds of
dark arts imaginable
the types of magic that he performed and
experimented with
made voldemort's horcrux creation look
fairly commonplace
but christus was alive during the 15th
century and he's the original inhabitant
of the island fortress of azkaban
while traveling one day acrisdas
stumbled upon the island
which at the time had no infrastructure
to speak of
when he first arrived it was just a
regular island
but he soon turned it into his own
little dark arts experiment
after placing concealment charms on the
island accidents began his dark arts
experiments
by luring muggle sailors to the island
then torturing and eventually murdering
them
before ever stepping foot on the island
a christus was mad but
after spending some time there he became
totally insane
as he had completely lost touch with
reality he became so wrapped up
and enthralled in his experimentation
with dark magic
that he had lost his mind and the poor
sailors that he brought to the island
witnessed it first hand in his madness
it has been speculated
that accidents either unwittingly or
perhaps intentionally created
what we now know to be dementors which
are the most evil creatures in the
wizarding world
the most evil creature from the most
evil wizard
makes sense and that's it for this video
what do you guys think of my list
comment your own list down below until
next time
remember of the horcrux wickedest of
magical inventions
we shall not speak nor give direction
you